[Music]
the unlv offense has been humming at
home their second straight 50 burger in
their home building north texas got the
better of them in a bowl game eight
years ago well this one wasn't close
well technically the first half was only
a three-point lead at the half but out
of the gates comes doug bromfield this
is his highlight we're just living in it
ricky white going top shelf he had seven
catches 76 yards and a score then
brumfield over to kyle williams
leaving you dizzier than the tequila
shot he's a blur and he's into the end
zone it would stay a three-point game
halfway through the third and this is
when brumfield is going to convince you
on why he won this starting job
rolling
scrambling
and giving up the body flipped on his
head and he still scores what an effort
he would be okay though one of his four
touchdowns on the day and of course the
home crowd giving love where it is very
much due how about a little cherry on
top aidan robbins had himself a day 229
yards on the ground two scores the
exclamation point here and folks the
rebels have matched their win total from
2021 in just three games positive vibes
all around the program at the moment
58-27-5